The ribber.
Drop Stitch Lace technique can create
a beautiful lace-like fabric
without any stitch transfers.
Imagine lace on a bulky machine.
The knitting is done mainly on the ribber.
Then needles are selected on the main bed,
and this creates a lace texture.
Now, this is one of those techniques
that I think has been greatly ignored over
the years, and I believe it's
because it can be a bit confusing.
We are used to working on the main bed,
and this technique is worked in reverse.
The knitting is on the ribber.
Before we get to the actual technique,
please take time to understand
how Drop-Stitch lace is created.
This video has two parts.
First, we'll work the technique manually
on the main bed,
putting the ribbing needles into work
manually to get a feel for how
this whole thing works.
Then we'll turn things around,
put the knitting on the ribber,
and let our main bed automatic
patterning select the needles for us.
Drop-Stitch lace is basically stockinette
with elongated stitches,
creating open spaces.
It adds a pretty texture to both the knit
and the purl sides of the knitting.
I started by casting on a single
bed with a ribber comb.
I just cast on full needle rib, hung
my comb, and dropped the ribber stitches.
Now, this is a ribber technique,
and we're going to be dropping stitches.
So we need good even
weight on the knitting.
My carriage is on the right,
and I've raised my ribber.
The ribber carriage is connected.
The ribber is set for full needle rib
racked to H, and the carriage is threaded.
Just randomly,
I'm going to create a little design,
and I'm putting every fourth ribber
needle into working position.
And I knit to the left.
Notice the loops over
those ribber needles.
Now I'm going to drop those ribber loops.
I'll disconnect my ribber carriage,
pass it across, drop the loops,
pass it back, and notice we've
got some loops hanging out here.
We need to pull down to make
sure they're out of the way.
We'll take any ribber needles out of work
at this point.
I'll knit one row to the right,
and that completes the first sequence.
I'll put more ribber needles into work.
Knit left, create some loops
on the ribber needles.
Drop those loops.
Take the ribber needles out of work,
and knit back.
So you can see that the ribber
needles aren't actually knitting.
They're not forming stitches.
They're just gathering a loop
across every other row.
That's it.
That's the idea behind Drop-Stitch lace.
But you can see that manually selecting
the ribber needles isn't
the most practical idea.
Let's put our automatic
patterning into play.